des moments rares teinté de convivialité
steve le dernier de la famille est
l'objet de toutes les attentions
le jeune homme vit à londres mais
pendant ces cinq prochains mois il
rentrera régulièrement ici retrouver ses
parents une joie largement partagé on
essaie de le gâter surtout de faire des
choses qu'il aime beaucoup des petits
plats comme on est un peu anti ciel dans
la famille donc on lui fait de planter
une tente alors cette fois comme il est
arrivé de nuit on a passé trop de temps
lui a fait une carte au lambi des petits
plaisirs et des séquences souvenirs
souvent ponctués d'éclats de riom steve
est une fierté tous le répète à l'envi
la première fois violé vu arriver en
martinique avec sonabhy parce qu'il
était dans l'équipe agit là effet le
voir pour arriver à fort de france
je vous assure c'était que du bonheur
que du bonheur on ne peut pas qu'on ne
peut pas expliquer on ne peut pas
expliquer son producteur de positive la
seule chose qui a changé
c'est plutôt mon admiration civetta pas
s'il était d'avoir 3 5 ans vous voulez
toujours le ciel pape a obtenu à bâle et
puis il m'a dit un jour bava bon je vais
sauter les étapes
il m'a dit un jour papa joe pilote est
toi tu sors mon tropisme
[Musique]
steve a aujourd'hui 31 ans après des
études de management et une licence de
pilote privé
il décide de partir se former en
belgique puis en arizona
il devient pilote professionnel en 2015
année au cours de laquelle il obtient
une qualification spécifique à dubaï
pour piloter ce type d'avion le boeing
depuis mai 2016 il travaille à la
norvégienne en qualité de co pilote
il débute donc sa deuxième saison en
martinique par le vol inaugural fort de
france cayenne avant de partir il ya le
briefing obligatoire avec le commandant
de bord au menu des discussions plan de
vol météo et plein de carburant bonjour
je peux commander monsieur pour le vent
levé à cayenne alors est ce qu'on peut
avoir 87 cents au delà dans les
obligations du copilote il ya également
ces nombreuses vérifications sur le
tarmac aux internautes
et c'est vraiment
niveau mais quelques points stratégiques
que nous allons vérifier si tout est en
ordre nous regardions vérifications des
moteurs des roues de la carlingue du
train d'atterrissage
on avait un très bon
gardez ont conçu au niveau extérieur on
fonctionne bien les moteurs on est en
très bon état et
donc il n'y a rien à signaler et nous
sommes bon pour le départ